とパワーを
先生から勉強できないん
んんんんんん
んぶーん
今日はこっちへスピーカーんです今日はその
パーを先生から勉強りゃーへ是非明日スマーター
僕と一緒に冷気で勉強の言葉を勉強しましょうか
それではですねなぜそういうテーマかっていうと
今日はね僕のところへその電子メールが届く前届けました
それはその宣伝の電子名
その会社かね
自分のそのウェブサイトでその英語を教えている
絞りた先生が揃っているから a
h の5財布のサービスを使ってくださいとしかしその
タイトーがですね看板がねその生徒のついてないじゃなくて先生のついてない生徒が
半分位両足
の出版しますというタイプだったんですよ
そうですかじゃあそれそれならその先生のついてる子達というか
生徒達ですね言葉を勉強している人たちがどうですか
成功しますか
で google をすればねちょっと調べたところでですね
例えば英国で
学校でですね80%の
正教徒がー
このフランス語やドイツ語を勉強してですね話できないです
だから先生がついててもそんなにうまくいかないようです
なぜかというと何よりもムーティべーしょんですね
先生が言ってもいなくてもモティベーション
ボティベージュがなければ先生がいっ
でも勉強できないもうてべーションがいれば先生があってもいいしなくてもいいです
それはまあ僕の場合はすべて
もうリンクでの影響しますよね
先生は前によってですねある程度
たくさんとの新しい言葉を聞いたり読んだりいろいろ自分でその発見した後でですね
ええ
オンラインでね wink のチューター頼んで話もするけれども基本はですね
うちのシステム内法システムで
あの僕の数字に合うような材料を探してそれを
聞いたり読んだり
知らない単語を調べたり全てリンクの機能を吸っ買ってある程度の数以上になってから
3選手を探すわけですよ
でそれは何回もやったことあるんですよ
あの
最近10年ですねあの
ロシア語や韓国語やポートが小屋
b 照度や今アラビア語やっぱり所が同じ良いことなんですよ
やはり
同期なんですよ同期と
勉強ショルシステムが必要なんですよね
先生というのは
やはりこの動機を与える
一つのあの源中ですか
一つのその要素であるありうるわけですよ
あの僕もありアラビア語べきと時にその他色のもフェイサーんですねあーアラビア語の
その先生というが球体が非常にあの
性格のいい
佐野我慢強いあの園カリーナね
その先生あったわけですよしかし大部分の者の時間あるいは努力
それは
僕は自分でやったわけでしょなぜなぜならばやはり
モティベーションがあったわけですよそのモティベーションというのは微妙なもうなん
ですよ
あの言葉を勉強するときにあの
いわゆる
基本のフェイス基本のパターン日本の合意を繰り返して繰り返して聞くという
立てばにのみに1人みたいなものですねそれそれはやはりあのこの断固
声
取らないといけなんですよ
内容はそれほど
内容自信を持ちろこないけれども言葉を勉強したいから
[音楽]
パティオも白いなよ難しいけれども面白い
だからないよそろそろもう一つの動きっ
例えば僕はにょ
日本に着いたのは1907年17日年
在所使ってたのはですね長沼シーズンそれが長沼へ先制の快感
品なんですよ出版は1950年
ヘラがばかりやつで僕は中国をしてたわけですから
感じも
やってできたわけですからひらがなになれんまい
慣れないないといけなかったんですよだからそうよつまらないものすごいつまらない
けれどもどうしても日本語話したくない話ししたいから勉強したいからと
だからつまらないものにしてもやり
も読んだ読んだ読んだキーか
読んだり読んだりしたわけですよそれからあとある程度
基本的なものできた江戸来てできてから
昭和の記録という nhk のそれも60羽年後
出版ですけれども
何回も何回も来ました
昭和の歴史にファイッ
日本の
デロンそので死亡かに入ったと面白いから面白いから
動機があって先生がいなくて僕は日本に入った頃はです日本語の先生は一人もいなかっ
たんですよ
全部自分で勉強しましたもちろん日本に住んでて周りの環境全部日本語ですから周りの
人みんな日本人ですから
それはやはり日本に住んで5便救出している人たちと違いますよね
誰でも中国語を勉強したのがいわゆる北京語を勉強したのが香港
香港は周りの人が
方あのぺ器具お話ししなかったんじゃな当時はれ
しかし先生が言った先生が言ったけれども他の生徒よりも僕と同じように外交官でね
色んな国該当か
含めてその日本日本人の外交官も含めてですね
あのもともと目立ちやはり誰よりも早くべきた勉強できた
なぜかというともうてぃべーションターン3 yonda
たくさん聞いたジャッジその時にたくさんふむ買って読んだり聞いたりしたのが今の
21世紀ですね2021年です
全てやるやりやすくなっている
ねっ office も使えるリンクも使える
youtube も使えるオーディオブックも
いわゆる
の
んですかいいぼく何でも使えるわけですよ
だから
勉強ししやすくなっていますだから必要なのは
モーチベーション
先生が言っても
いってもいいわいいおしかしモティベーション
自分で面白いものを探さないでください
自分に合ったような勉強方法も探さないといけない
先生が
いってしかし妹言うじゃなくて自分に合うような勉強法をも探さないと多分
失敗します
だから
先生がいないと半分の人た人が失敗しますそれが正しいだろ
しかし先生が言っても半分以上の人が失敗することも多分正しいと思いましただから
最終的にはいわゆる日本語で言うと up to you です
じゃ玉
ビーン
んんん
ん
うん
[音楽]